a few moments ago Buckingham Palace
announced the death of her majesty Queen
Elizabeth II the queen died peacefully
at Balmoral this afternoon
had the queen passed away in England
operation London Bridge would have been
activated there were plans in place for
her to be transported from Sandringham
and from Windsor but because the queen
has died at Balmoral in Scotland
operation unicorn has been activated and
the queen will lie in state in Edinburgh
before being transported possibly by
train or the Queen's flight back to
London the Queen's body will remain in
Scotland for now she will lie in state
in Edinburgh before being brought back
to England where she will line State at
Westminster Abbey before making her
final journey to Saint George's Chapel
in Windsor and it is in Windsor where
she will be interred along with the late
Duke of Edinburgh her husband Prince
Philip we are expecting a briefing and
tomorrow from Buckingham Palace where
further details of the Queen's funeral
are due to be confirmed and the bridges
planning is something that has been
tweaked and amended particularly after
the coronavirus pandemic there are
potentially two options for the Queen's
body to be brought back to England that
could be by train but I think more
likely than not it will be via the
Queen's flight
[Music]